[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
CASEY RODRIGUES: So I'm
going to prove a few theorems
about limits, which will
allow us to compute limits,
or at least we can use to prove
that other non-trivial limits
exist using these
theorems, rather than using
the definition directly.
So this first theorem is the
easiest theorem in the world
because it's simply just
restating the definition
of convergence of a sequence.
So I'm going to state it as
follows, so pretty short,
that if I have a
sequence x sub n,
then it converges to x if and
only if the sequence obtained
by taking the absolute value
of x of n minus x equals 0,
or the limit of
that sequence is 0.
So what is the proof?
It follows just immediately
from the definition.
So I'm not even going
to write anything.
I'll leave it to you.
But the proof follows from the
definition and the simple fact
that x sub n minus
x in absolute value
is equal to the absolute value
of the absolute value of x sub
n minus x minus 0, OK.
So the definition says
for all epsilon positive,
you have to find an M so that
this is less than epsilon
for all m bigger than
or equal to capital M.
But if you found such a
capital M for this to be less
than epsilon, then
this will be less
than epsilon, which is saying
that this limit equals 0.
And then going the other
direction, it's the same thing.
So this is just
following directly
from the definition
and this simple fact.
OK, that was a very
silly fact about limits,
but a very useful
one in conjunction
with the next theorem,
which is not so trivial,
which is the squeeze theorem.
And it says the following.
So let an, bn, and
xn be sequences such
that the following
holds for all n
natural numbers, a
sub n is less than
or equal x sub n is less
than or equal to b sub n.
And a sub n and b sub n
are convergent sequences.
And their limits
equal each other.
And they're given by
some number, call it x.
Then the conclusion
is that the limit as n
goes to infinity of
x sub n equals x.
So when I write something like
this, you should also kind of--
there's half a sentence
before that that
goes with this saying, x of
n is a conversion sequence.
And its limit is equal to x.
So it's two statements
in one when I write that.
So if you just draw a
picture, the squeezed theorem
shouldn't be too surprising.
So this is a little discussion.
So here's x, the common
limit of a sub n and b sub n.
And so we can imagine that we're
trying to show the limit as n
goes to infinity of
x sub n equals x.
So that means we have to find
for every epsilon a capital M
so that x sub n is
between x plus epsilon
and x minus epsilon.
So if I go out a
little bit, I would
hope I can find
a natural number,
a capital M so that
x sub n minus x--
or x sub n is in
this little interval.
Now, if I'm assuming that a
sub n and x sub n, if a sub n
and b sub n are squeezing
x sub n, in other words x
sub n is between the two, and b
sub n is converging to x, then
for n bigger than or
equal to some integer M0,
all of the b sub n's
are in this interval.
OK, maybe they're not there.
Maybe they could be over here.
But the way I drew it is
just to the right of x.
And, likewise, since a
sub n is converging to x,
there exists some
other integer M sub 1
so that if I look at a sub n,
it's also in this interval.
Maybe it's over here.
Maybe it's-- well, it can't
be to the right of b sub n
because that inequality up there
strictly implies that a sub n
is less than or
equal to b sub n.
But it's in this interval.
So then what would
that say if I look
at n bigger than or equal to
n plus M1, M0 plus M1, then n
is bigger than M0, this guy.
And n is bigger than
both and M1, this guy.
And therefore if
I look at x sub n,
it's going to be
between these two.
And in particular, it's
going to be in this interval.
So that's the
proof in a picture.
And now our goal is
just to write it down.
So that's the
picture of the proof.
But if you're actually trying
to guess why this would be true?
I mean, the b sub
n's, you can imagine,
are getting very close to x.
The a sub n's are also
getting very close to x.
x sub n is in between
the two, so it's
getting squeezed to
x, and thus the name.
OK, so now we just need to
turn this into written word.
So we need to show--
we're going to show that
x sub n converges to x.
So we're-- all we have is
an epsilon delta proof.
Or we could use that theorem.
But let's go with an
epsilon delta proof.
I mean, not epsilon delta,
epsilon M. Epsilon delta proofs
will come later.
So let epsilon be positive.
And since b sub n
converges to x, there
exist to M0 in natural numbers
such that for all n bigger
than or equal to n sub 0, b sub
n minus x is less than epsilon
in absolute value, which is
the same as saying-- well,
I mean it's not the same.
But it implies that b sub n
is less than x plus epsilon.
Since a sub n's
converge to x as well,
there exists a M sub
1, natural number,
such that for all n
bigger than or equal M1,
a sub n minus x
in absolute value
is less than epsilon,
which implies
a sub n is between x minus
epsilon and x plus epsilon,
but I'm only going to use
one of those inequalities.
Now I'm going to choose the
capital M for my sequence
x sub n, I'm trying to
show convergence to x.
So choose m to be m
sub-zero plus M sub 1.
I mean, you could have chosen
it to be the maximum of the two.
But this works
just fine as well.
Then if n is bigger
than or equal to m,
this implies n is bigger
than or equal to M0
and M is bigger than
or equal to M1, which
implies that both of
these inequalities
here are valid for this n.
So then x minus epsilon is
less than a sub n, which
by assumption, is less than
or equal to x sub n, which
is less than or equal to b
sub n, which is less than x
plus epsilon.
Now, these string
of inequalities,
therefore, tell us
that x minus epsilon
is less than x sub
n is less than x
plus epsilon, which is
equivalent to saying
the absolute value of x, so then
minus x is less than epsilon.
And therefore x sub
n converges to x.
So these two facts together give
us a very robust and short way
to prove limits of sequences.
So, for example, let me
give you a simple one.
Let's show the limit as n goes
to infinity of n squared over n
squared plus n plus 1 equals 1.
So, I mean, this is
a very simple limit
to use these theorems on.
But in practice,
you don't always
have just a simple
expression like this.
And we'll use these two
theorems in conjunction
to prove some other
theorems here in a minute.
But let's just see
it in action once.
Let me look at--
so this sequence
converges to 1 if and only
if the absolute value of the
difference converges to 0.
So let's look at the absolute
value of the difference.
This is equal to-- now
just doing the algebra--
this is equal to--
and taking absolute
values gives me n plus 1
over n squared plus n plus 1.
And this is less
than or equal to.
This 1 is making things
bigger, so I can drop it.
And this is less than
or equal to n plus 1
over n squared plus n.
Now, n squared plus n I can
factor into n times n plus 1.
So then that cancels with
this n plus 1 on top.
And I just get 1 over n.
So 0 is less than or equal
to n squared over n squared
plus n plus 1 minus 1, which is
less than or equal to 1 over n.
Now, 1 over n we've shown
using epsilon delta proof--
I mean, epsilon M proof.
We've shown 1 over
n converges to 0.
So since 0 converges
to 0, the left side,
and 1 over n converges
to 0, the right side,
that implies by the
squeeze theorem,
n squared over n squared plus
n plus 1 minus 1 converges
to 0 by the squeeze theorem.
Which implies that
n squared over n
squared plus n plus 1 converges
to 1 by that first theorem.
OK now you can imagine
that instead of having this
at your disposal, I asked
you to do an epsilon
proof, an epsilon M
proof of this statement,
then you would have taken
this and played with it
just like we did here
and gotten to 1 over n.
And therefore if this
is less than epsilon,
that would imply this
is less than epsilon.
So you would choose
capital M to be--
so that 1 over capital
M is less than epsilon.
But using these two theorems
saves us a little work
and a little time.
OK, now, so at the end
of the lecture last time,
we discussed the
notion of subsequences.
And we showed that limiting--
limits and subsequences
interact nicely, meaning if
I have a convergent sequence,
then every subsequence
converges to the same thing.
So now a natural
question is, how
do limits interact with the
order of the real numbers?
R has these two fundamental
properties about it,
that it's--
so first off, that it has the
least upper bound property,
and also that it's
an ordered field.
So first natural
question is, how
does this definition of
limit convergence interact
with the order?
So the first theorem states, or
this term that kind of answers
this question is the following
is that limits respect order,
basically.
So if xn, yn, are convergent
sequences and for all n,
xn is less than or
equal to yn, then
what should be the conclusion?
The limit as n goes to infinity.
So what I said a minute ago
as limits respect inequality.
Then I should be able to
take the limits of both sides
and still have this inequality.
Then limit as n goes to infinity
is less than or equal to limit
as n goes to
infinity of y sub n.
And a simple corollary
that follows from this
is that if x sub n is
a convergent sequence,
and for all n a natural number,
you have two numbers a and b,
such that a sub n is
less than or equal to--
or a is less than or
equal to x sub n is
less than or equal
to b, then this
implies that the limit of x
sub n is also between a and b.
Let me say something
very brief about what
this says and doesn't say.
So what does this not say?
You may lose a strict
inequality, meaning what?
It can be the case that x
sub n is less than y sub
n for all of n, but
the limit of x sub n
equals the limit of y sub n.
So simply having less than x
sub n less than y sub n does not
imply the limit of x sub n is
less than the limit of y sub n.
All right, so what
do I mean by this?
This does not imply that the
limit is less than y sub n.
Now, at this point in
class, I would ask somebody
to give me a counter example.
So at this point, I'm going
to take a bite of my cookie
and let you think about that.
I didn't have to take
a bite of my cookie.
You could have just paused the
video and thought about it.
But then I wouldn't get
a bite of my cookie.
OK, so what's an example of two
sequences that satisfy this,
but don't satisfy this?
If x sub n equals 0 for all n,
and y sub n equals 1 over n,
then the x sub n is less
than y sub n for all n.
And what's the limit x sub n?
Well, that's just 0.
And before the limit of
y sub n, that's just 0.
And these two things
equal each other.
This is not less than that, OK.
So just want to make
that small point.
Could pop up as a small question
on one of the midterms--
I should say the midterm--
and possibly the final.
All right, so let's prove--
[COUGHS] let's prove 1.
2 follows immediately from one.
For two, we simply
take, for example,
the upper inequality
x sub n is less
than or equal to
b, we take y sub
n to be the constant sequence b.
And for the other one, we
would take the bigger sequence
to be x sub n, and
the smaller sequence
to be the constant sequence a.
So two follows immediately from
1, so we're just going to do 1.
And we haven't done a
proof by contradiction
in a while, so why not
do it by contradiction?
OK, so the proof--
let's label these
sequences so I don't
have to write limit as n goes to
infinity, and limit of x sub n,
and limit as n goes to
infinity of y sub n so much.
So let's call their
limits x and y.
And what do we want to show?
x is less than or equal to y.
That's our goal.
And we're going to prove
this by contradiction.
That is, let's assume
y is less than x,
and arrive at a false
statement, which
contradicts our setting our
assumptions that we have.
Assume y is less than x.
Now, let me draw a
picture here to go along
with what's going to happen.
So if y is less than
x, all of the y sub n's
have to be near y if
I go far enough out.
And all the x sub n's
have to be near x as long
as I go far enough out.
So that would
contradict eventually
the fact that the x
sub ns are supposed
to be less than or equal to the
y sub n's, if y is less than x.
And let's say I
go out, let's say,
half the distance
between y and x.
So this is like the midpoint.
And all the y sub n's are here,
and all the x sub n's are here,
and the y sub n's are here, then
I cannot have x sub n less than
or equal to y sub n,
which is my assumption,
which is the assumption
in my theorem.
Now, maybe I should
have written this here.
Sometimes it's good to reiterate
what your assumptions are.
Suppose for all n, x sub n
is less than or-- y sub n.
And-- like that.
And so the thing we're
trying to show is this, OK.
So we assume the
negation of this
and arrive at a contradiction
to the things we're assuming,
or just to general true facts.
I had to add the word true on
the facts, because they're,
like I said, at
some point there's
alternative facts
flying around out there.
OK, so this picture, we're
going to turn this into a proof.
So since yn converges to y,
there exists a natural number
M sub 0 such that for all
n bigger than or equal to M
sub 0, y sub n minus y is
less than x minus y over 2.
Now, that's a positive
number, because we're
assuming x is bigger than y.
And by the definition of limit,
given any positive number,
I can find an integer
so that for all n bigger
than or equal to that
integer, this thing
is less than that small number.
And I'm just choosing
that small number
to be this very
special small number,
because that's going to help
me arrive at a contradiction.
Since xn converges to x,
there exist M1 natural number
such that for all n bigger
than or equal to M1, x
sub n minus x is less
than the same thing.
OK, so this is putting
into a precise form what
I was saying that
all the x sub n's
to be close to x eventually.
And all the y sub n's to
be close to y eventually.
And how eventually?
Well, eventually enough so
that I'm in these two disjoint
intervals, OK.
Let n be M sub 0 plus M sub 1.
Then n is bigger than
or equal to M sub 0.
And n is bigger than
or equal to M sub 1.
So both of these inequalities
are valid for this n
and what does this mean?
Well, then that
implies that y sub n--
so let me tack on
one more inequality.
Just by removing the
absolute values and adding y,
this tells me y sub n is
less than x plus y over 2.
And this tells me x
sub n is less than--
or the other way, sorry.
Well, we'll just
write this down here.
So
Then y sub n is less than
y plus x minus y over 2,
which equals x plus y
over 2, which equals
x minus x minus y over 2.
And this is less than x sub
n by the second inequality.
So this follows from
the first inequality.
This follows from the
second inequality,
which implies for
this specific n,
y sub n is less than x sub n.
And this is a contradiction
to our assumption
that y sub n is bigger than
or equal to x sub n for all n.
So we had just found, based
on this assumption here,
that we arrive at
a contradiction
to our other assumptions.
And therefore this
must be false.
So that's how limits
interact with inequalities.
So if I have two
sequences, one bigger
than the other, then the
limits respect that inequality.
That has to deal with
the order part of R
being an ordered field.
So what about the field part
of R being an ordered field?
So how does limits interact
with algebraic operations?
All right, quite
well, it turns out.
So let's in theorem.
So suppose I have two
convergence sequences,
limit as n goes to infinity
of x sub n equals x,
and limit as n goes
to infinity of y sub n
equals y, then
several things hold.
The first is that, again,
you should kind of read this
as two statements written
in one, limit as n
goes to infinity of
x sub n plus y sub n.
So this is a new
sequence that I formed
by just taking the term-by-term
sum of these two things.
This sequence, this new
sequence is convergent.
And the limit equals the
sum of the limits, OK?
The second is, for
all c in R, the limit
as n goes to infinity of
the new sequence obtained
by taking every entry
of the sequence x sub n
and multiplying it
by this fixed number
c, the limit of that product
is the product of c and x.
So limits respect what one would
call scalar multiplication.
But we could be more
general than that.
c you can think of
as just one example
of a convergent sequence,
just a constant sequence.
But, in general, we
have that the product
of two convergent
sequences is convergent.
And the limit of the product
is the product of the limit.
And, finally, if we
have something for--
write it over here--
if we have something
for a product,
then perhaps we have
something by quotient.
And that's as long as
we can divide things.
So if for all n, y sub
n does not equal 0,
and the limit y does not equal
0, then limit of the quotient
x sub n over y sub n is the
quotient of the limits, OK.
OK, so we're going to
prove this first one using
this scheme of using both this
simple theorem about limits
and the squeeze theorem.
And it's quite simple.
So we just use the
triangle inequality.
By the triangle inequality, 0
is less than or equal to x sub n
plus y sub n minus x plus .
And x sub n minus
x, y sub n minus y.
And then I use the
triangle inequality.
I get x sub n minus
x plus y sub n--
oh-- you know
what, scratch that.
Because, in fact, I was
trying to be too clever
and would have ended
up using the theorem
to prove the theorem.
So let's not do that.
It's never good to
use the theorem you're
trying to prove to prove
the theorem that you're
trying to prove.
So let's go back to basics
and use the definition.
Let epsilon be positive.
So since x sub n converges to
x, there exists a natural number
M such that for all n bigger
than or equal to M0, x
sub n minus x--
it's supposed to be a n,
but it looks like a k--
less than epsilon over 2.
Why the 2?
Well, you'll see in a minute.
And similarly for
the sequence y,
there exist M1 natural
number such that
for all n bigger than or
equal to M1, y sub n minus y
is less than epsilon over 2.
So I have these
two integers, which
are given to me by the fact that
x sub n converges to x, y sub n
converges to y, and the
definition of convergence.
I can always find
these two integers
for any small tolerance.
And I'm choosing
the tolerance to be
epsilon over 2 for some reason,
which you'll see in a minute.
And so what is the
integer capital M
that I choose for this epsilon
for the sequence x sub n plus y
sub n?
I'm going to choose
M to be M0 plus M1.
And now I need to show that
this choice of M works.
And if n is bigger
than or equal to M,
this implies that n is
bigger than or equal to M0.
And M is bigger
than or equal to M1.
So both of these inequalities
are valid for this n.
And therefore I get x sub n
plus y sub n minus x plus y.
And now I do what I was
going to do a minute ago when
I was going to use the
theorem to prove a theorem.
x sub n minus x, y sub n minus
y, I group those together.
And then I used a
triangle inequality.
This is less than
or equal to x sub
n minus x plus y sub n minus y.
And now this is less
than epsilon over 2.
This is less than epsilon
over 2, so equals epsilon.
And now you can see
why I chose the 2.
Because I wanted to show
this was less than epsilon.
And I had control
over these two things.
And the sum of controls
gives me epsilon.
So I choose the control
to be epsilon over 2.
If I had three
sequences, then you
could probably guess though
which is epsilon over 3.
Meaning if I had
sequences x sun n y sub n,
and z sub n, and I
looked at sum x sub n
plus y sub n plus z sub n,
I could show that converges
to the sum of the limits.
And I would choose
these integers M sub 0,
M sub 1, M sub 2, so that
I have epsilon over 3 here,
so that they sum up to epsilon.
So now we prove 2, that for this
single scalar multiplication
if you like where
you just multiply
each term by a single
number, the limit
respects that multiplication.
Do an epsilon proof again.
Since x sub n converges to x--
so now we're trying to
show that second limit--
there exists M sub
0, a natural number,
such that for all n than
or equal to M sub 0,
x sub n minus x is less than
epsilon over the absolute value
of c plus 1, OK.
And now you have to
trust me, why that thing?
Well, you'll see.
It'll come out
just like this did.
So for the sequence
c times x sub n,
we'll choose M to be
just this M sub 0.
Then if n is bigger
than or equal to M,
which is equal to M sub 0, this
implies this inequality holds.
And therefore c times x
sub n minus c times x.
This c pops out of
the absolute value
and becomes the absolute value
of c times the absolute value
of x sub n minus x.
And which is less than-- so
I'm writing less than here.
But this thing is
less than that.
[INAUDIBLE] is less than
c over c plus 1 epsilon.
Now, this quotient here, this
number over this number plus 1,
is always less than 1.
So this positive number
which is less than 1
or non-negative number
is going to be less than
1 times epsilon, which
gives me epsilon.
And maybe you're wondering
why didn't I choose--
so this is just a little smidgen
of sophistication, not much,
just a little.
Why didn't I choose
this so that it's
epsilon over the
absolute value of c
so that when I stick in
my inequality for this guy
I just get epsilon?
Well, what if c equals 0?
So then I'm telling you to
choose capital M sub 0 so
that the absolute value of x sub
n minus x is less than epsilon
over 0.
Division by 0 is a no no.
But if we fudge it
a little by adding 1
we get something that
still does the job.
It still gives me
some number which
is non-negative and less
than 1, which is enough, OK.
So let's prove that the
limit of the product
is the product of the limits.
Since the sequence y
sub n converges to y,
it's a convergent sequence,
and therefore it's bounded.
That means that there exists
some non-negative real number
b such that for all
natural numbers n,
y sub n is less than or
equal to b in absolute value.
Then I look at x sub n times y
sub n minus x times y and I add
and subtract x times y sub n.
You can write this as plus.
And now I use the
triangle inequality
that this is less than or equal
to x sub n minus x times y sub
n plus y sub n minus y
times absolute value of x.
And y sub n is bounded
by b for all n.
So this is less
than or equal to--
plus y sub n minus y times
the absolute value of x.
Now, let me just state
the obvious that we
get 0 is less than or
equal to x sub n times y
sub n minus x times y.
And this is less
than or equal to,
as we've shown here, plus
x times y sub n minus y.
Now, the right-hand
side-- so the left side
of this inequality
converges to 0.
The right side
also converges to 0
because we've just
shown by 1 and 2.
By 2, this converges to 0.
And by that theorem, since xn
converges to x, this product
here converges to 0.
b is a fixed number.
And the same thing for
this, that converges to 0.
And therefore by 2,
this sum converges to 0.
OK, so these two
arrows are by 2.
And this is by 1.
So let me just
summarize by 1 and 2
the right-hand side
of this inequality,
b times x sub n minus x plus an
absolute value of x times y sub
n minus y.
This converges to 0.
Which by the squeeze
theorem implies that--
this is by squeeze theorem--
which implies that x sub n times
y sub n converges to x times
y by that first theorem.
So I'm not going
to keep referring
to that first theorem.
Because it's such
a simple fact, I'm
just going to keep using
it without referencing it,
namely that the sequence, a
sequence converges to x if
and only if the absolute value
of this thing, this difference,
converges to 0, OK.
All right, so that proves
the limit of the product
is the product of the limits.
Now, for the
quotient we can use 3
once we've proven it
for just 1 over y sub n.
So what do I mean?
So now we're assuming the y sub
n is not equal to 0 for all n.
And y does not equal 0.
So if we prove this
statement that the limit as n
goes to infinity of 1 over y
sub n equals 1 over y, then by 3
implies that the limit
as n goes to infinity
of x sub n over y sub
n equals x over y.
Because x sub n over y sub n
is just a product of x sub n
and 1 over y sub n.
So we just need to prove this
special case if you like.
And we're to do it
kind of the same way.
Now because we're
dividing by y sub n,
so here we use that we had an
upper bound for the product
here.
But when we take 1 over y sub n
to get an upper bound of that,
it means we need a
lower bound on y sub n,
on the absolute
values of y sub n.
And we get that by our
assumption that the limit is
non-zero for all n, and
so is the y sub n's.
So first thing we prove, or
let me write this as a claim,
there exists a positive
number b, little b,
such that for all
natural numbers n,
y sub n is bigger
than or equal to b.
And we know that a
sequence is bounded.
So we know that there's
always a capital B
so that absolute value of y sub
n is less than or equal to b.
But for sequences that are
non-zero and converging
to a non-zero limit, then you
can bound them away from 0.
And it's kind of the
same proof that we
gave for showing that a
convergent sequence is bounded
above.
So let me draw a quick picture.
And let's assume that the
limit is positive just
for the sake of the picture.
So this is a little discussion
on why this is true.
And this picture
is going to look--
at least the
explanation is going
to be kind of similar to
why a sequence is bounded.
And this one is why
is it bounded below.
So let's assume that
the limit y is positive.
And let's say I go
out within distance,
let's say, y over 2 so
that I'm still positive.
So this is y minus y
over 2, absolute value.
So in this picture
y is positive.
So that's just
equal to y over 2.
Then what can I say?
That eventually all of the y sub
n's are here in this interval
away from 0.
And, in fact, their absolute
value is bounded by y over 2.
So let me just
write it that way.
So all the y sub n's or n
bigger than or equal to some M,
all have to lie in this interval
because they're converging to y
and y is positive.
And therefore in absolute value,
they're all bounded above--
below I mean-- by y over 2.
They're all at least
distance y over 2 to 0.
OK, and then all that's
left to handle are--
maybe the finitely many
that are left, y sub 1,
y sub 2, y sub m minus 1, that
are scattered on the real line
but are non-zero.
So we're just going
to end up taking
the minimum of this number
and the absolute value
of these numbers.
So since the y sub n's converge
to y, and y does not equal 0,
there exist an integer
M such that all n bigger
than or equal to capital
M. So this picture
was why this claim is true.
It was not the proof of
why this claim is true.
What I'm writing now
is the actual proof
of why this claim is true--
such that for all n bigger
than or equal to a capital
M, y sub n minus y in absolute
value is less than y over 2.
So for this picture I
drew where y is positive.
That would have
just been y over 2.
But you have to use an absolute
value for the other case
that y is negative, because
this has to b a positive number.
Then for all n bigger
than or equal to M,
this any inequality and
the triangle inequality
gives me-- so if I look at
the absolute value of y,
this is equal to the absolute
value of y minus y sub n plus y
sub n.
And now I use a
triangle inequality,
which is less than--
this is less than y
over 2 plus y sub n.
And I started off with
the absolute value of y .
So when I subtract
that over, that
tells me that absolute
value of y over 2
is less than absolute
value of y sub n for all n
bigger than or
equal to capital M.
So then I let to b to be the
minimum of several numbers.
know I'm writing min,
but I should write inf.
But so if you like, let me
write inf of y1, Ym minus 1,
and y over 2.
And by what you are
doing on the assignment,
I think it was the
assignment 2, this inf
always exists in a finite set.
This is a finite set
of positive numbers.
And therefore it's
infimum exists
as one of these elements.
One of these M numbers
is the infimum.
And they're all positive, so
this is a positive number.
And so then simply how
this number is defined,
it follows that for all n, y sub
n is bigger than or equal to b.
Because, again,
if n is between--
little n is between 1
and capital M minus 1,
then certainly that the
absolute value of that thing
is bigger than or equal to the
smaller of all of these, which
is bigger than or equal to b.
And if n is bigger than
or equal to capital M,
then we proved over
here that y sub n
is bigger than the
absolute value of y
over 2, which is bigger
than or equal to the minimum
of these numbers and y
over 2, which equals b.
All right, so that
proves the claim.
That proves the claim.
But we haven't proved
what we wanted to yet
that the limit as n goes to
infinity of 1 over y sub n
equals 1 over y.
But this follows
almost immediately
from what we've done so far.
So now we're going to use
the claim to prove it.
So we look at--
compute that the 0 is
less than or equal to 1
over y sub n minus 1 over y.
We're going to
show that this goes
to 0 using those two theorems.
And so by algebra
that's equal to--
and using the absolute value,
this is 1 over y sub n minus y.
I mean, the absolute
value of y sub
n minus y over absolute value
of y sub n absolute value of y.
Now y sub n is bigger
than or equal to b.
So this is less than or equal
to 1 over b times y times
y sub n minus y.
So just to summarize, we've
shown that 0 is less than 1
over y sub n minus 1 over y
is less than 1 over b times
1 over--
b times the absolute value
of y times y sub n minus y.
Now, this goes to 0 because
it's just a constant sequence.
This converges to 0 because y
sub n minus y in absolute value
goes to 0.
This is just a fixed
number of times that.
And by what we've proven for
2, this product converges to 0.
So by the squeeze theorem, we
get that 1 over y sub n, this
converges to 0, which implies--
OK.
So another big property
about the real numbers
that we proved after
we stated the existence
of the real numbers,
which remember was this
is defined as this ordered
field with a least upper
bound property.
We proved that the square root
of 2 exists as a real number.
There was really
nothing special about 2.
In fact, you could prove
that the square root of x
exists as a real
number for any x that's
a positive or
non-negative number.
So the square root of a
real number is well defined.
Or the square root of
a non-negative number
is well define and always
exists as a real number.
So you can ask how does limits
interact with square roots?
And they interact just
as you think they should.
If I have a sequence
so that for all n,
x sub n is bigger
than or equal to 0,
and it's a convergent sequence,
converging to some number x,
then the limit of the
square roots of these guys
equals the square
root of the limit, OK.
Now, I want you to just take
a second here and understand
that this is a
meaningful statement.
Because since the x sub n's are
all non-negative by a theorem
that--
let's see, did I
erase it already?
The one that had to deal
with limits and the order,
so since the x sub n's
are all non-negative,
that implies that
x is non-negative
so that the square
root is meaningful.
OK, so first check
whenever somebody says
here's this theorem,
or this theorem is--
I think this theorem is true--
is to check to make sure
that a theorem is meaningful.
So let's prove this.
So there's two cases to
consider, x is equal to 0
or x is non-zero.
So let's do the first case.
So the limit is 0.
So we'll do this proof using
the definition of limits,
meaning the epsilon
M definition.
So we want to show that the
limit of the square root
of x sub n equals 0.
So let epsilon be positive.
And since x sub
n converges to 0,
there exists
natural number n sub
0 such that if n is bigger
than or equal to M0,
then x sub n minus the
limit, which is just 0,
and taking the absolute
value, which is just
x sub n, which is
equal to x sub n
because x sub n is non-negative,
is less than epsilon squared.
Remember, I can
always find, no matter
what is underneath my hand,
since x sub n converges to 0,
I can find a natural number
so that that thing is less
than what's underneath my hand.
And the thing that I'm going to
have underneath my hand that's
going to make things work
out for the square root
is epsilon squared, OK.
Choose M to be M sub 0.
So I'm going to show this
M works for the sequence
square root of x sub n.
And n bigger than or equal
to M. The square root
of x sub n minus 0,
which is just x sub n.
Now, it's also-- so we didn't
strictly speaking prove this--
but it's not too hard to show
that square roots respect
inequalities.
So x sub n is less
than epsilon squared.
So the square root
is less than epsilon
squared, which equals epsilon.
So the second case
is x not equal to 0.
And to do this case, we'll
use those two theorems again.
And let's look at square root of
x sub n minus square root of x.
Now, if I write this as--
and multiply top and
bottom by x sub n
plus square root of x,
square root of x sub n
which is a positive number.
It's fine to divide by it as
well, because x is non-zero.
So here not just
non-zero, it's positive.
Because x has to
be non-negative.
Now this is the
product of something
minus something else with
something plus something else.
So then that's going to be
the difference of the squares.
So that's equal to--
over-- and, again, these
are positive numbers
so that they come out
of the absolute value.
And this is non-negative.
So, in fact, it's only making
things bigger on the bottom
and therefore things
smaller overall.
So this is less
than or equal to--
just if I replace this
by square root of x.
So what did I prove?
1 over square root of x--
all right.
And so by assumption,
x sub n converges to x.
So this goes to 0.
This is a fixed
number multiplied
by this thing going to 0.
So by number 2
and the theorem we
proved before, this whole
product converges to 0.
So, and of course
this converges to 0.
So this thing in the
middle must converge to 0
by the squeeze theorem.
So that's the square root.
And let me just remark that--
so this number 3 up here,
that the limit of the product
is a product of the
limits, this thus
implies that the limit of xn
squared converges to x squared.
So the square of
x sub n converges
to the square of the limit.
And by induction, you can show
that the cube fourth power,
fifth power of x sub n
converges to the fourth power,
fifth power of x.
And not only that,
you can also prove--
so I'm not going to do this.
And I'm not going to
force you to either.
But just know these
as facts, that I
don't have to just
take the square root,
I could take the k-th root.
And this statement still
is true that if x sub n is
bigger than or equal to 0 for
all n, and I have a limit,
then the k-th root
of x sub n converges
to the k-th root of x.
So the final theorem
we'll prove for today,
which will conclude our facts
about limits, is we have--
I mean, we've been
using this all along,
although I haven't made
special attention about it.
The real numbers
there, this, again,
like I said, an ordered
field with a least upper
bound property.
So we've seen how limits
interact with this structure
of the real numbers.
But they also have a
distance associated
to them, the absolute value.
The distance from
two numbers a and b
is the absolute
value of a minus b.
Or the distance
from a number to 0
is just the absolute
value of that number.
So one could ask,
how does the limit
interact with this
additional structure
of the absolute value?
And so just like everything's
been good so far with limits,
it's the, same with the
absolute value namely
that limits respect
absolute value.
So if x sub n is
convergent sequence,
the limit x, then the
sequence of absolute values
is also a convergent sequence.
And the limit as n goes to
infinity of the absolute values
equals the absolute
value of the limit.
Now let me, again, let's try
to think a little more deeply
about this real quick.
If I have a convergence
sequence and the absolute values
converge, does
the converse hold?
If the absolute values
converge, does this
imply that the original
sequence converges?
And the answer
is, of course, no.
Well, not of course.
I didn't even give you a
minute to think about it.
But why is the
converse not true?
So let me make this a remark.
Converse is not true
because you could look at x
sub n equals minus 1 to the n.
Then the absolute
values of these guys
converges, but the original
sequence does not converge.
So this is a one-way
street for convergence
and the convergence of
the absolute values.
So before I prove
this theorem, let
me just prove a quick
inequality which
I think I said I was going
to put on the assignment,
and then forgot to
put on the assignment.
But you should know it.
So this theorem is the
reverse triangle inequality
which states for all a, b real
number, the absolute value
of the difference in
absolute values is less than
or equal to the absolute
value of the difference.
OK, so the proof of this
reverse triangle inequality
just uses the original
triangle inequality.
So absolute value of a, this
is equal to the absolute value
of a minus b plus b.
And this is less than or
equal to the absolute value
of a minus b plus
absolute value of b.
And thus the absolute value of
a minus the absolute value of b
is less than or equal to the
absolute value of a minus b.
Now, these are just two
numbers, I mean two letters,
reverse the letters.
In this argument replace
a with b and b with a.
So then I get b minus
the absolute value.
The absolute value of b
minus the absolute value of a
is less than or equal to the
absolute value of b minus a,
which is the same as this.
And therefore-- let me
multiply through by minus 1,
and that tells me--
OK, so I have this is less than
or equal to the absolute value
of a minus b.
I also have it's
bigger than or equal
to minus the absolute
value of a minus b.
And therefore the
absolute value of a minus
the absolute value of b is less
than or equal to absolute value
of a minus b.
So I it's taboo to write
on the very back board,
but I'm going to do it anyway.
So that was the proof of the
reverse triangle inequality.
Here's the proof of
the theorem before it.
It just follows from the
reverse triangle inequality
and that combination of those
two theorems over there.
We have that the
absolute value of x sub n
minus the absolute value of x.
This is less than or equal
to, by the reverse triangle
inequality, the absolute
value of x sub n minus x.
So this is by the reverse
triangle inequality.
And by assumption,
this converges to 0
as n goes to infinity.
So by the squeeze
theorem, this goes to 0.
And therefore the absolute
value of x sub n converges
to the absolute value of x.
And that's it for that proof for
this lecture and for this week.